our action rights needed to create a
truly equal Society
[Music]
can you explain
like what do you mean by abortion rights
the right to an important you guys have
it here up to six months but in the US
we don't it's an American channel so
yeah so our abortion rights needed to
create a truly equal Society
I don't even understand the questions
should abortion be allowed oh yeah you
should have a choice
what of course I am uh I think abortion
should be illegal and however I do
obviously we have common law in this
country I do think that there should be
some kind of uh you know common law
um where under specific circumstances
you might qualify for one but I think
the general standard
um legislation should be that it's
illegal and then under certain
circumstances or situations which like I
think they're pretty obvious we all know
um then it should be allowed and also
like if it's um you know if the child is
is gonna be born like disabled or
something I I do agree that maybe you
should be able to decide if if you want
to I don't know that's a really
difficult one I'm not gonna get into
that because I don't actually know how I
feel about that but generally I don't
really believe in abortion at all really
what about you
no I I would like to have that option I
would definitely like to have that
option
um things happen in life and you know I
might fall pregnant and I'm have you
fall pregnant
well I don't know things happen by not
being careful
I I fall pregnant takes all the
accountability off of you yeah but if I
become pregnant yeah but if I become
precious and God forbid my husband lost
his job and you know we're not really
great financially whatever the
circumstances are and we are not fit to
raise children of course I want an
abortion and I should be allowed to do
that are you typically with men that
don't have jobs and can't raise children
I hope not but we never know what will
happen in life you know so you you gotta
have I would like to know that I have
that option but you have the action of
contraception so why not pick that
option first and think preventatively
instead of um reactionally yeah
precaution not always 100 so I agree
things happen no it's 99.5 effective if
you get an IUD I had the contraception
pill and I got a child it didn't work
for me
like did you get the IUD and wear a
condom too I didn't I don't work I
wouldn't ever consider that with my
partner but I had the conceptive pill
and it didn't work and it's 99.9
effective which one did you take
um what's it called good morning after
Paul yeah was it the five day or the
free day one
um so long ago I don't really know but
it didn't work you took the morning
after pill yeah
I did that's like the last case I don't
take contraception so like I did take
the morning after pill and it did work
yeah but that's a choice to not be on
birth control yeah I don't I'm not on
birth control which is why I said I
agree with you I believe that you should
have the option but I think the options
that you choose in terms of not keeping
a child
I think you have to I believe that you
should be able to justify them like if
she's not meant if a woman feels she's
not mentally stable to have the child or
for all the right reasons I think if
you've got options to do everything else
then I do believe you should have that
option that's my opinion up to up to how
many months oh no no I don't like it has
to happen immediately if you do if it's
like you've got a bump and I don't agree
with that I think that's wrong
so here it's up to six months do you
agree no no no no no that's too far when
do you agree with it immediately no
that's too far I think that's right
immediately like as soon as you know if
you believe that you don't want a child
you've got to act really quick and I
believe that everyone's body's a bit
messy because so you might still be
bleeding you know what I mean anything
past like seven eight weeks and I I
don't I don't know just don't think
that's right yeah a lot of people don't
even find out until like after two
months I know a couple people that
they're like three months and they're
like this is your last day to choose I
have somebody asked me to take them to a
clinic in London when because I'm from
Birmingham when she was like six months
and I wouldn't wouldn't do that couldn't
do that
that's a full grown baby yeah I
understand it's got a heartbeat as soon
as you're pregnant but that's a full
grown child you've had long enough to
decide and you understand like people
are completely against it I respect that
but I just don't I think the woman
should have a choice how do you not know
for two months
to me it's just being bailed out for a
bad decision it's just weird like at the
end of the day take birth control or
don't have sex
or don't sleep with or don't sleep with
people that wouldn't be good Fathers or
if you're not financially safe stable
yeah
if that's not as simple people
not having a baby but that's not easy I
don't think it's an excuse that people
have one night stands and I don't even
think that we should be saying like oh
people have one night stands to [__]
like it doesn't have to be a one-night
stand that's the way you get pregnant
though like it just happens and you
could actually happen you could actually
be in a committed relationship and then
it could an abortion whatever reason it
could happen that way but you can make
choices so it doesn't happen
but it doesn't change the fact that it
does happen but my whole thing is it's a
bailout for poor decisions because at
the end of the day if you get pregnant
you made a poor decision I agreed if you
didn't want to be pregnant yeah and
there'll be a lot more illegal abortions
though like people will be going to like
back corners and I think it's better to
do it the proper way well obviously
there's no proper way to think but like
the proper way is surgically everything
then to go to back Corners down
abortions are performed oh yeah they're
really nice
they pull off the limbs one by one so
they pull off the leg then we pull off
the next leg then they pull off the arm
and the other arm then they they crush
the skull and vacuum it out is that is
that true yeah that's true that's how
many months are like five six months you
can have that done like as soon as it's
gotten the other way the other way it
starves the kid and it like falls out
and I had a girl on the show explaining
her abortion at like two three months
and she said she was shocked by how
informed it was because it had like a
full head a whole I think she said it I
can't remember the exact stuff she said
but she said she was shot because a lot
of the pictures like they don't really
inform you of that yeah I thought I feel
like I'm on the fence to be honest
because I feel like everyone should have
the right to have a choice of what they
would like to do with their body however
like what you just explained to me I
don't agree with that because life and
um but what about the baby's trust so
what about the women right baby what
about the women what about the women
right in cultural Traditions who get
pregnant and if they don't get rid of
that child their life's on the line like
how would you justify that they are
responsible but they're also in a lot of
danger if they're gonna die yeah this is
what like this is what people always do
with the abortion arguments they always
usually extremes 99 of abortions are
elective but 99 so it's like you're
using the one percent argument to
justify the whole thing if I said okay
give you give you those abortions in the
life of the mother would you be okay
with Banning the rest
that are from poor decisions true I
understand I do agree with what you're
saying in terms of it being a poor
decision but I still think I still stand
with what I believe I agree
people make silly mistakes all the all
the time but it's not like somebody
that's sticking with them for Life yeah
and you know I know a lot of girls that
don't make the same likes and don't get
pregnant it's not like people make silly
mistakes all the time
if you're irresponsible I also think
like you know you said about um like
Backstreet abortions and illegal
abortions or whatever I
sure Naturally that that might happen
but I also think it's possible that if
women don't have the option for abortion
but they might be more careful because
you can you imagine like if if we were
living like how we all are today
um and like let's say like you go out
clubbing you find someone you have a one
night stand or whatever like I don't
know like contraception because I'm not
feeling like oh my God like if I had to
go in for an abortion like I just think
the fear of that like I think over the
last three years I've certainly gathered
that fear controls people and fear like
instills certain behaviors in people and
I think by not having the option for
abortion generally speaking say 99 of
the time
um I think women would just sort of wise
up we're not silly if you know that it's
going to be difficult to do something
you'd avoid doing anything that would
lead to that being the consequence
that's just what I think it's actually
true
I don't agree of abortion I just believe
that people should have a choice I don't
agree with it because I don't think
she'll take that last year however
I do believe that we should have a say
do you think that women should be
limited on how many abortions they can
have oh yeah oh definitely yes
definitely definitely because after that
first time you shouldn't even be wanting
to make stupid mistakes at that again it
should be a lesson do you think men
should ever say an abortion yeah yeah so
do you think if if I got pregnant and I
wanted to abort it and a guy wanted me
to keep it should he ever say yeah yeah
he has a say but you have to come to a
like a legal say yeah like both both
parents need to sign off on the abortion
yeah that would be very practical I
think I think that is correct yeah
because she could have the baby and then
like he she might not want it say for
example I understand there's a burden in
carrying a child but we have to be
responsible in a sense mutual agreement
then yeah I'll get that I think that'll
be hard because it'll be easy to just
say I don't know who the father is I
feel like a lot of people would do that
I feel like a lot of people would
probably say they don't know who before
but there's ways to find out if they are
the father so if a man wants the child
then I think that's really unfair to
take that away from me you know I really
definitely because when you become a mom
like you're so happy you've got baby
like for someone to steal that away from
me or like change their mind three
months in and you're so happy to take
that away and you've got no saying it
that's heartbreaking of course
but also I feel like maybe these women
would would I mean would they be
changing their minds because of
something very serious or is it just um
that women have the right to do that but
I just think at a certain point after
pregnancy there's you can't be chopping
and changing because yeah from when you
tell your man is you're pregnant like
he's in his element so to take that away
from him he's still in his dream because
it will a lot of us dream of having a
family so I just think you can't jump
and change that 50 his DNA why doesn't
he get 50 of the choice I believe he
should have 50 of the choice but then
what would happen if they don't agree
yeah no they have to agree in order for
it to happen yeah so what if one is
continue saying nope another saying yes
then it won't happen then it wouldn't
happen yeah
okay that's why I was saying they both
have to sign off for in order for it to
be an abortion
do you guys think that women should
serve jail time if they allow a man to
raise a kid that's not his 100
definitely that is so evil I think it's
so Jamaica we call that Jackie basically
you gave someone a jacket yeah that is
really really yeah it's horrible I
definitely even think that's a crime
definitely because a man imagine you're
raising that child you create a bond you
love them you give them your all
financially spiritually everything and
then to find out when they're 20. that
should be like a life sentence like yeah
for 15 years and then you find out it's
not it's nice that should definitely be
punishment for that yeah that is
horrible but then on the flip side there
is we're living in a time where guys can
get DNA tests so yeah yeah but if you've
told someone it's their child why are
they going to be a native it's illegal
in France to DNA test really oh wow I
think I think it's either they both have
to sign off on it so if the woman
doesn't want him to she can just
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible